setting boundaries improves your
confidence because
you're actually regarding yourself your
time as important
as worthy of something when you don't
have any boundaries you're basically
sending that signal to your subconscious
that
you're not important you don't matter
everybody else matters a lot more than
you
why is being empathetic and driven an
interesting combination for people to
have yeah you know i think we
don't think of them together i think we
don't think about the
combination of traits and and challenges
that
happens when we bring together those two
qualities of someone who is
highly sensitive so observant empathetic
kind
but also very driven in their career
it's interesting isn't it because a lot
of the
qualities that people think of when they
talk about being driven sort of ruthless
uh quite self-centered um
not really caring about others sort of
the the sociopath
wolf of wall street type kind of
approach um
but success can be driven by a number of
different factors right
absolutely and yes exactly where you're
saying we traditionally
think of success of business with
someone who is
fast someone who is merciless uh with
action
we don't equate it with reflection and
careful thinking
and kindness and compassion which
is odd because what the research shows
is that actually
those traits actually lead to higher
performance better teams higher revenue
so it's counterintuitive that combining
those two things would actually
create better results because it's the
opposite of everything we've been taught
and told
and conditioned to believe and it
prevent presents
a very specific set of problems
right that need a very specific set of
solutions and that's what we're going to
go through today
so one of the the terms that you're
going to relate to a lot is a
sensitive striver so let's define our
terms before we get into it what is a
sensitive striver
a sensitive shriver is a person who
combines those two aspects of someone
who
is highly sensitive meaning they think
and feel
everything more deeply but they are also
high achieving
so they are driven they reach great
heights in their career
they may not necessarily aspire to be
top of the pack and
ceo but they have a strong drive to be
the best version of themselves
and so when those two qualities come
together it can be
a tremendous asset and a superpower but
can also
lead to a very specific uh set of
challenges that comes out of that as
well
how can people identify if they're a sen
sensitive striver is there an mot that
people can run through a checklist
absolutely and so i you know i should
specify that being a sensitive shriver
is about we're talking about 15 to 20 of
the population here so
one in five people i'm sure everyone
watching watching or listening to this
know someone who is a sensitive shriver
or works with them
or is one themselves and so
sensitive shrivers they are highly
attuned to their own emotions
as well as those of other people we are
deeply caring we give our 100 to our
work
all with an inner world on overdrive so
we
process information more deeply than the
average person we're more
uh affected by our surroundings
which again makes us observant
perceptive we
anticipate in eventualities we are the
person who is able to
spot opportunities or highlight gaps
before things become a problem
but at the same time being so
affected and processing everything so
deeply can also
lead to stress overwhelm overthinking
especially if you don't have the right
set of tools
what are some of the main disadvantages
that you get as a
sensitive striver how does it hold you
back yeah
so it might be helpful to go through uh
the framework i've defined in the book
of really identifying yourself
the qualities of being a sensitive
shriver and we can talk about that
because each one has
an upside to it but also has a downside
to it that i think will provide
more color so uh in the book
i share this strive framework very easy
to remember
sensitive shrivers your core qualities
are strive
and this is the place i start with
anyone who comes to coaching or works
with me in any of my programs
because it's very overwhelming to be a
sensitive person
you can feel like there is so much you
want to
improve or change about yourself or be
different that
you don't know where to start so the
strength
drive framework is a way of prioritizing
where your biggest opportunities are
our first quality the s probably
unsurprisingly
is sensitivity now i know that may seem
obvious
that of course a sensitive shriver is
sensitive duh
but this specifically refers to sensory
sensitivity so it is having a more
uh exaggerated nervous system or a
heightened
nervous system response to everything
that's happening within and around you
so again you are attuned to your
environment
you're attentive to what's going on
you're very perceptive
but at the same time you can become very
easily
overstimulated so when sensitivity your
sensory sensitivity
is balanced or able to be calm and
composed even when there's a lot going
on around you
but if not you can be very very easily
stressed you can have a very
um exaggerated uh
fight-or-flight response so many times i
will see unbalanced sensitivity come up
with
people speaking up in meetings or being
put on the spot for example people get
paralyzed and freeze
when put under pressure in that way
because they just go into fight or
flight and don't know how to deal with
it
so that's our first our s which is
sensitivity
then we have thoughtfulness which is the
t and
you know sensitive shrivers we are very
uh
creative reflective we contemplate
issues we're intuitive um but at the
same time if your thoughtfulness is not
managed
that can become overthinking imposter
syndrome
self-doubt indecision criticism uh we're
almost so self-aware that we're the
hardest person
on ourself because we're so aware of our
own behavior
so we have our s our t then we have our
r in the strive
which is responsibility and that is uh
more of the striver
side which uh sensitive shrivers we're
dependable
we can be we follow through we have a
high drive for
commitment and dedication but at the
same time
we may over function we may take on more
than our share of responsibility
we make people please and put other
people's needs ahead of our own
so we are the one who will sacrifice our
own weekend
and you know work 10 hours to get a job
done so we're
really willing to sacrifice our own
well-being we're overly responsible
at times that brings us to our eye which
also
is the striver side so the i stands for
inner drive
and you know sensitive shrivers we are
the one who wants to exceed expectations
in everything that we do we want to
check the boxes get the a
plus so we set a lot of goals and we
usually achieve them
but sometimes we can over burden
ourselves with too many goals
we can overwork because we want to reach
the next
next echelon of our career and probably
most of all we can fall into
perfectionism
where we have this very binary
all-or-nothing view of success
either i accomplished my goal and i'm
amazing or i didn't and i'm a failure
uh and sometime that perfectionism can
lead us to
set such an unrealistically high bar for
success that we
end up setting ourselves up for failure
because it's not something
that can be accomplished so then we have
our
v which is for vigilance and that's
being very attuned to the subtleties
in your environment and nuances going on
around you
so sensitive shrivers we are very good
at reading people
we can sense a change in somebody's body
language
even over zoom or just pick up on the
general mood
of a meeting for example so again very
attuned to the environment but it's
almost as if your antennas
are up all the time just gathering
information about what's going on around
you
which can be really draining on your
battery
and most of all we tend to read into
situations even when there's not danger
there we can perceive something as
dangerous like
getting some benign feedback but
thinking oh my gosh it's the end of the
world and i'm going to get fired
uh that's our vigilance on overdrive
and then our lasti is emotionality so as
you
probably guessed and sensitive shrivers
who are listening or watching
can attest to that we have big complex
feelings about a lot of things both
positive and negative
so we are the one who can experience the
richness
of positive emotion and inspire that in
others
joy gratitude excitement but we can also
get stuck
in emotional spirals anger fear anxiety
and stay stuck there longer than most
people if we don't have the right
tools a basis for this
in is it biology or neuroscience as well
that's been discovered can you explain
that
yes so the trait of high sensitivity in
particular has been studied for over
30 years and the original researcher who
discovered it dr
elaine aaron uh found that it was
a biological and evolutionary
trait that evolved because it kept
a certain amount of people in the group
safe it was very beneficial in
prehistoric times to have someone who
was deliberate and thought before they
acted you wanted someone who didn't just
rush into an unknown situation you
wanted someone who
paused before they acted so that's why
the trait of sensitivity has
existed and persisted over time
because it does provide an advantage and
they have found
that this trait of high sensitivity
exists in over
100 different species so everything from
you know dogs to insects
can be highly sensitive and you know the
research also shows that
people who have this trait of high
sensitivity tend to have different
brain patterns so we have different
activation
in parts of the brain related to things
like
attention concentration action planning
decision making and another
interesting finding is that our mirror
neurons
so the part of the brain the neurons
that are responsible for
empathy understanding people being able
to read behavioral
nuances we tend to have more active
mirror neurons so our brain lights up
more
when we see social interaction or we see
someone upset for example our brain
lights up more
um so it's very interesting that it's a
very real thing
because i think for most people who are
sensitive shrivers or just highly
sensitive
at least for me i know my whole life i
grew up trying to stifle
this and just thinking what's wrong with
me why am i inadequate
why am i so fragile and i can't get it
together not realizing that
it's a part of my personality and once i
named it identified it
and understood it could actually use it
and leverage it as a superpower that it
actually is
one of your uh clients or followers i
think
summarized it in the book in the best
way that i saw where they said
i over everything and
that's just such a good way to put it
because it is it's just all of the
all of the things that you do turned up
to 11. all of the sensitivity
and the interpretation and the
overthinking and
everything just gets turned up to 11.
and um yeah i'd say
i i think i would probably
fall somewhere on the spectrum of this
i'm going to guess that sensitive
striver skews female
is that right you know that's a very
interesting question
and first you're absolutely right that
is it it is a spectrum
it's not a binary thing just like you
can be on a spectrum
of introversion to extraversion and some
people are in the middle as ambiverts
it's the same thing
so you may relate to some of these
qualities more strongly than others and
that's
completely normal um
but you know the research does actually
show there's not
a huge difference in the number of
men who are highly sensitive versus the
number of women
now anecdotally what's really
interesting is the more that i've talked
about
sensitivity and become more you know
public
with this as a part of my business and
my personal story
the more men i've attracted into my
community and that i've worked with in
my coaching
services and programs so that's that's
been an interesting discovery
but you know i think socialization
really does affect how
sensitivity shows up so for women in
particular
we're always told don't be so emotional
right women are the emotional gender
they say
and young girls in particular are really
groomed to be perfectionist we're really
groomed to follow all the rules
and be a good girl and you know
certainly i i can relate to that that i
wanted to be a good girl and please
everyone and
most young girls by the time that
they're in their preteens
about half say that they cannot fail
that they are not allowed
to fail which is a really
really dangerous conditioning for young
women um
and so they we take that into the
workplace with us and
it can form something i call the honor
roll hangover which is that
um that conditioning those qualities
really following you over
into your career so for a lot of women
we face that double bind as well because
we have to be
we can't be overly emotional but we have
to be empathetic and warm
but we also have to display confidence
so it's a tight rope
for women whereas for men so many of
them grow up with
conditioning that says you can't be
sensitive you have to
be macho and be tough and don't cry
you know only sissies cry so a lot of
sensitive men
really disown that part of themselves
and only you know later in their lives
when they discover this is a very real
thing
uh come around to actually owning it
i think what you identify there is that
when we try and force people into boxes
or archetypes
inevitably everybody loses because if
you have a pre-prescribed idea of where
someone's supposed to go
and the out that their internal state
doesn't match that external state
everybody whether you send women too far
left or men too far right
it still ends up being and i would
totally totally agree i think
for a significant period of time i saw
my empathy as a weakness
and still i it would be nice if i could
give some of it away i've got
i have it if there was a button yeah
just to turn it down a little bit i
could just give some you know like
charitably
um but after a while
you do realize okay like this is a
relatively
immutable source code part of myself
and it's probably it's probably not
going away so i might as well learn
to make it as good as i can or to to
utilize it
and one of the advantages of that is
that it means you can
get insights about the world and about
the people around you and about yourself
that very few other people can and
that's a competitive advantage
um for the the guys or the girls who
have absolutely no sensitive striver in
them
and are fearless and are able to just
make decisions and roll with the punches
and deal with
obstacles as they come the results there
are also competitive advantages to them
but your competitive advice you're not
going to beat me on on finding insight
it's just not going to happen you're not
going to be a better podcaster than me
because you can't
tell all of the different nuances about
what's happening in the conversation the
way that someone feels and looks and
their body language and their tone and
that
all that stuff but i'm also not going to
be able to run a
high paced high pressure high stress
business organization that requires a
million decisions a day
with kind of flow
thought as opposed to forethought and
planning because that's that's your
wheelhouse
and um i really do think that the
sensitive striving thing i like
giving things a name without putting
them into boxes classing it as a
paradigm i think is a smart way
to kind of uh give it a label
but also it really does identify such an
odd oxymoron as we went back to before
what does it mean to be empathetic and
driven at the same time what are the
unique challenges
that that gives people but what are the
unique opportunities and then how can we
double down on those opportunities
there's a quote that you have from glenn
glennon doyle which is
awesome says i understand now that i'm
not a mess
but a deeply feeling person in a messy
world i explained that now when someone
asks me why i cry so often is for the
same reason i laugh so often
because i'm paying attention i had
jordan peterson on the show
a couple of weeks ago and he was talking
about the difference between
looking and watching he says attention
attention isn't looking it's watching
it's watching to see what happens it's
watching to see what the other
person's doing taking in everything that
you can and um
yeah the question of whether it's a
blessing or a curse to feel things so
deeply
is one that i guess curses only
sensitive strivers but um
that's that quote really sort of sums up
a lot of interesting insights i think
yeah yeah and when i when i read that i
was like oh
that one hit me and you know i think
there is
there is so much there to the uh
aliveness and the awakeness
of being a sensitive shriver but that
that gets to balancing
these qualities because so many times
sensitive shrivers
are on autopilot on autopilot trying to
overcompensate for their insecurities by
trying to do more
and prove themselves and source their
self-worth through
achievements and validation from other
people that
we're we're we're giving all of our
attention
away to others and we're not channeling
any of it
inward um or being
uh slow with with our attention like you
were saying rather than just fast
and reactive to everything that's
happening around you for really actually
taking it in
and leaving room for that processing
because to me that
that's the difference between uh looking
and watching
is that watching goes a layer deeper of
having meaning
and interpretation and purpose to what's
going on around you
you talk about this on a role hangover
which is
straight-a students that have come
through school or college or university
and then they get into the workplace and
they constantly feel this need to over
deliver
they're likely to be perfectionists
they're likely to be people who will
reread the email 20 times before they
send it and
stuff like that how can people get past
that if i'm just pinging off all of the
different things that someone that's
listening to this does
they think that's me and that's me and
that's me how can someone get past this
yes and so you know the the honorable
hangover
is i define as that intersection of
perfectionism
people-pleasing and over-functioning so
the perfectionism piece as you were
as you were saying kind of overdoing it
but really perfectionism is about
self-criticism and being hard and
judgmental on yourself
the people pleasing putting others
before yourself knocking down your own
opinions in favor of others
and the over functioning is being the
one to swoop in
to fix every situation uh taking on
responsibility
and it creates a dynamic
where if you are over functioning
you create a dynamic where others can
under function
so you actually disempower them because
you're fixing everything and doing
everything for them they don't have to
think for themselves
so when uh the the first way to really
start
unhinging yourself from the honor roll
hangover
is you have to make more space
in your life because with the honor roll
hangover you typically have
what i call goal collected you've
typically taken on
all of these ambitions and and aims and
obligations
many from yourself because you want to
push yourself to achieve more and do
more
but also because you feel overly
responsible or somebody
else said this would be a good idea to
do or you just feel some sort of sense
of
obligation like a a good employee would
be involved
in this initiative right and so
in the book i call it the strategy of
giving up goals
which is really taking stock
of how you are spending your time and
looking for areas where you
need to rethink a goal or priority or
give it up
all together how can you identify those
so the first one is looking for places
where the goal was not yours
in the first place where you were driven
by a sense of
comparison or as i said obligation
anywhere where you are telling yourself
you should
you have to you need to do something
versus wanting to do something very
important distinction there
so you want to make sure that anything
you're undertaking
is really motivated by the right fuel
that you are motivated by an inner
longing and desire
rather than a fear of missing out
so that would be one a big one that i
see for sensitive shrivers is when
giving up the goal when it starts to
bring you more distress
then starts to bring you benefit and
this is a really important one i have
been here
many times in my life where in the
name of pushing myself outside my
comfort zone
i push myself way outside my comfort
zone
to the point of you know dread sleepless
nights
uh in the in the book i tell the story
of my own very severe
burnout that my goals really led me to a
place where i was having heart
palpitations my hair was falling out
and those goals were bringing me a lot
more distress
almost death than benefit and so
yes i am all for discomfort
in the book i have a whole chapter about
taking on more risk and getting
comfortable with discomfort
but there comes a point and you have to
develop inner discernment
to know when a goal has pushed you far
beyond your comfort zone to the point
where it's damaging your health
and then the last one i would say is
when you're fixated more on the
results and the outcome then you are on
the process
so if you are fixated entirely on
getting
a title a certain salary getting your
business to a certain
uh revenue rather than the process it
takes to get there
for example you want to you know scale
your business
to a million followers let's say
but you don't want what comes along with
that
the uh building the internal side of
your business perhaps managing a team
creating more content to support that
big of an audience
then that is a sign that you might want
to rethink that goal as well
i can't remember who it was i want to
say seth godin i was talking to
and he was he was discussing exactly the
same thing talking about how many people
want to be a rock star but hate playing
the guitar
you're like no you don't understand
it's the other way around you want to
love to play the guitar and rockstar
will come along for the ride
you talk about uh fake it until you make
it what are your thoughts about that
you know for the most part um i don't
love
the phrase because fake it till you make
it suggests being something you're not
right and so many sensitive shrivers the
honorable hangover
tricks us into thinking that we can
fake it till a point where we have
earned worthiness and approval
if we only check a certain amount of
boxes or meet
a certain requirements and so i think in
that way this idea of fake it till you
make it pushing yourself
further uh in the name of trying to be
something you're not can really
lead you astray and in the wrong
direction
that's interesting so you're saying that
fake it till you make it it's kind of
like
there's also almost a sense of
self-deception
in there saying that i'm not good enough
for this thing it inherently implies
that you need to have ticked these boxes
before you can get to a particular level
i'm going to guess that fake it till you
make it also feeds into imposter
syndrome
somehow oh 100 yeah because if you're
uh if you think you're an imposter you
will
just fake it and put on a mask and
pretend to be something you're not so
that people
won't think europe imposter and what i
really think
is most uh is the biggest slippery slope
with fake it till you make it
is that we we bypass looking at the real
problems we especially with imposter
syndrome
we just think well if i look and i act
confident
then i will feel confident rather than
addressing
what's really why am i not confident why
am i not confident what are the thoughts
that are that are generating that
feeling how do i deal with the emotions
of shame and doubt rather than wrestling
with the difficult things
we try to bypass we try to go over
instead of through
well also ask yourself do you deserve
imposter syndrome this did come from
seth godin
where he said if you're doing a thing
that you've never done before
you quite rightly deserve your imposter
syndrome you are an imposter you haven't
done it
yeah it's it's like i reframed it as
adventure syndrome
if you are mapping new territory then
how do you know if you're going to be
able to succeed or not but on the flip
side of that
this is something that i try and tell as
many people who bring up imposter
syndrome to me as i can
your imposter syndrome should only be
able to survive being disproven in the
real world
so many times before it just leaves
if you start clinging on to it imposter
syndrome
and believing that you are not worthy of
the successes that you have
isn't the same as being humble and i
think a lot of people
believe that it is somehow that oh well
if i if i hold on to this imposter
syndrome it's keeping me rooted to the
floor it's like no no no
your goal is to have the most accurate
self-view that you can at all times
that's it and by holding on to your
imposter syndrome
if the imposter syndrome makes you feel
less than you are
that's inaccurate and if the fake it
till the make it makes you feel more
than you are that's also inaccurate
just try and have a relatively rational
world view about yourself and about your
capacities
100 yeah and you know whenever i talk to
people
about imposter syndrome i always say
exactly what you were saying that
sometimes
doubt is a normative response and where
it becomes impostor syndrome is when
your sense of doubt
is out of sync with your self perception
or
the facts of of the situation so if the
facts of the situation
are that you've never done something
it's unproven this is new to you
then it's completely normal to feel a
sense of doubt you're just having a
normal human response to
a situation versus imposter syndrome
would be
i've proven success here i've received
great praise and accolades
i have training in this area yet i still
don't feel like enough
and i still feel like every moment
someone's going to
come along and say i'm a fake and i'll
be found out
so that's a very important distinction
and i don't think a lot of people
realize we group them together yeah and
the fake it till you make it as well is
going to
it's going to cause a buffer to sit
between you
and whoever is complimenting you or the
award that you win or the accolades that
you managed to achieve you've hit this
year's target
well yeah but i was faking it until i
made it so
that still isn't internalized and um
that basically means that you're kind of
strapping yourself to the tree that is
your own fake it till you make it
imposter syndrome you're just going to
stay there
so you split the book into three
sections and you go into the second
section now where you talk about
what people should give themselves
permission to do what should they give
themselves permission to do
yeah you know a lot of things um but
specifically
permission to succeed so many sensitive
shrivers are
afraid to be who they are they're afraid
to do
well because they're afraid of success
which is sounds funny to say that
someone could be afraid of success but
you can um and so they need permission
to succeed to feel like
they're not outshining others or they're
not the tall poppy that's going to get
cut down
what will people think of me if i do
well
and specifically to get out of their own
way thinking that there's one
right way to accomplish something that
someone out there prescribed that
there's
certain steps you need to take or an
exact model that exists
and you just need to find it that's not
how the world works
so you need to get give yourself
permission to
take matters into your own hands listen
to yourself
and starting before you feel ready
starting before you feel completely
qualified or prepared
that would be first yeah i was going to
say just how can people
what what are some of the techniques
that people can do to instantiate that
yeah you know some of this is what they
need to stop doing
and so with with our type of personality
in particular sensitive strivers
we tend to over prepare and we get into
procrastal learning as i call it which
is
a diversion tactic of
over researching i will have clients who
will
uh say they want to accomplish something
and then they will spend weeks
planning and putting together
spreadsheets and yeah but i need to put
together my
my strategy plan my business plan and
in all they over complicate and they
spend so much time
researching and thinking about something
rather
than just acquiring knowledge as they go
or i see this a lot with my clients who
are business owners for example
they will spend so much time creating a
website
when they don't even need a website
right now they could go out and get
clients through
referrals for example and so it's a
diversion tactic
to focus on the comfortable thing
instead of the thing that feels a little
more
challenging and exposing to us
um so that would be one way but but
another thing i love to go through with
my clients
is having them
remember and root into their own
resilience and even just going through
the exercise of reminding yourself
of three times in your life when you
have done something
difficult or challenging how did you get
through
it what did you learn from that can
really help you realize oh i actually do
have what it takes i've been in this
sort of situation before
i can navigate through this again
because often what blocks people from
starting before they're ready is the
self-doubt is the sense of inadequacy
that
i can't do this i don't know what i'm
doing i'm not good enough what are
people going to think of me
and so getting your mindset right will
mean that then your actions can fall
into place around
that because we always want to be
consistent with
our beliefs and how we see ourselves so
if you see yourself
as inadequate well guess what you're
going to keep hitting up against a brick
wall when you try to take action
but if you see yourself as someone who
is resourceful and figures it out as you
go
well then you're going to allow yourself
to take action in that direction
it's one of the beautiful things of
experience right as you
spend more time disproving your own
imposter syndrome and
coming up against different challenges
inevitably
you actually think well god how long can
i believe that i'm an incapable buffoon
whilst still disproving it in the real
world and then you have this
litany this huge library of past
catastrophes that you got through
and last minute submissions for work and
all the rest of this stuff
you think oh god there isn't much left
for me not to conquer
yeah i mean and i think that's one of
the
i think that's one of the reasons why
when we see
people in the business world who have
been in there for
you know a decade or a couple of decades
and still quite haven't
got past that needing to prove a point
constantly
feeling inadequate and you can tell when
you see somebody walk into a room and
sit down in a meeting i think that's why
that's so jarring
because you think come on you you've
been doing this for 15 years or 20 years
like chop chop you need to you need to
play catch up here
yeah there's a there's a proving energy
to it right versus i'm
i'm comfortable and secure yes
exactly how how do you channel emotions
into an advantage yeah you know i was
talking to
somebody else about this today and i
think an important distinction
here is that you can't have emotional
intelligence without emotional
regulation
and channeling your emotions into an
advantage you were talking about it
before
that that emotional insight and
attentiveness
you have to other people is what makes
you successful as a podcaster
and i i have one client who
once told me this great story where she
works in a large media company the
company was getting ready to do a huge
technology
overhaul and she because she was a
sensitive shriver
anticipated oh boy this is going to
cause some conflict and friction between
the product team and the technical team
and having that emotional foresight she
was able to go
to each of those teams go to one person
on each team and say hey
how are you feeling about this what's
coming up for you because she had known
there had been
some roadblocks with them before and
was the one who brought them together to
mediate
the conflict and really create a space
for those
emotions to come out and be channeled in
an effective way that
led to the collaboration being
successful if a sensitive shriver hadn't
been in that role it might have been a
complete
debacle that they were able to make this
technology change within a couple of
months versus
things like that can take years for
example and when you have someone who
has that emotional attunedness
that is how it can be an advantage
you're able to understand people's
motivations you can influence other
people
you can also use your own emotions to
persuade and motivate people
so so many of my sensitive shrivers as
managers leaders and business owners
they are highly effective and they are
the boss everyone wants to work for
because they are someone who cares about
hey how are you doing
how's your family they make you feel
seen and validated
they have a pulse on morale they know if
they can tell if you are feeling
if you're dragging or feeling burned out
and will work with you to help adjust
your workload or give you time off for
example
so you know the research shows that that
being someone who is more attentive to
emotions
makes you more successful it earns you
more money for example
teams with emotionally in touch leaders
are more
uh successful they're more innovative
because there's trust people feel like
they can take chances and they won't be
beat up or thrown under the bus for it
um but of course at the same time being
someone who is overly emotional
especially if you
if your strive qualities are unbalanced
can be a challenge
but those are some of the ways that it
can be a benefit and i don't think we
often put those pieces together to
see emotions as a strength because we're
taught keep your emotions out of it
emotions don't belong in business when
business is people so
something i've just realized there is if
there is a competitive advantage to
being a playmaker it seems like the the
sensitive
striver and the emotions would work very
well in a playmaker role multiple
different people very people-oriented
very
forward-facing perhaps internal as well
um if you are someone that has that
capacity
think about how hard it is for you to
fully open up and fully utilize
those skills accept the fact that you
feel and notice and uh perceptive of
what's going on
and then realize that not only is there
only a small subsection
of the entire workforce that has that
capacity but of the people that have
that capacity there's only a small
subsection of those people that are
prepared to utilize it
because everybody has the same level of
discomfort around utilizing it that you
do
so you say okay so i'll chop that down
and then chop this down you go wow
actually if i can just get past myself
if i can just get over this hump
there is a a very very small group of
people that i'm competing with with this
particular
talent pool because first you need to
have the talent and then secondly you
need to have the bravery or the courage
to actually be able to deploy it
yeah so yeah i think if that's if that
doesn't compel someone
to go okay right i'm gonna i'm gonna
utilize my empathy here i'm gonna
combine the empathy in the drive and i'm
going to use it to make me a more
effective business person
i think that should be that would be a
pretty big wake-up call for them
100 perfectly perfectly sad that's what
i like to hear
uh what can people do to end
overthinking obviously this is kind of
the the flip side of the coin right it's
all well and good it's talking about i'm
insightful and perceptive and i can tell
what's going on and i can foresee
problems between people before they
occur
but the flip side of that is you're
going to move more slowly because you
inevitably overthink complicated and
you're going to over complicate
situations how can people get past that
that's right yeah and so realizing uh
realizing when you're overthinking is is
huge here because as a sensitive shriver
your natural mode
is to take in more information and
process it more deeply
but when you realize you are starting to
hit mental dead ends
your thinking is starting to make you
stressed or anxious
or is just unhelpful that's when you're
overthinking
one of my favorite tools from the book
and it's just a it's a quick a tip but
it's really powerful
is naming your inner critic giving it a
name personifying it
creating an identity for it the little
monster
or the gremlin i go between the two um
but that is my inner critic for sure i
have had clients name there's darth
vader
for example all sorts of things
and you know it's fun the point is to
make it
a little more lighthearted so that
you're not so fused with those negative
thoughts that they don't feel so heavy
and damaging
to you but you can actually create some
psychological distance
and be able to put that pause between
okay automatic thought
and what do i want to choose to think or
what action do i want to take
going forward that's a very quick one
but definitely
one of my favorites so the overthinking
arises
you notice that you're starting to get
lost in a little bit of a thought loop
and you think oh there's there's darth
vader again having another top
that's right and then it gives you it
gives you that moment to
assess to assess like oh i see you i can
make a more conscious
choice rather than a reactive automatic
let me just spiral out and let me just
make a conscious choice
in that moment do i want to believe
darth vader do i want to buy into that
is there what does my what does my why's
inner voice tell me and want me to do
differently that's a
practice that many people that meditate
will be familiar with right noting yes
just providing that mindfulness gap um
james
altucher al altica has
the not useful label if you've heard of
that
yeah which i absolutely love so whenever
he notices a thought in his mind that he
realizes is not useful
he just notices labels it not useful and
it
disintegrates the veracity and and the
size of whatever it is you're thinking
about because you go
well i don't i don't want you i don't
want you in my mind but
until we realize that until we create
that mindfulness gap and give us that
give ourselves that distance i'm going
to guess that learning to trust your gut
is a skill that a lot of sensitive
strivers could probably do
with trying to acquire oh yes
because we are conditioned as sensitive
shrivers it's that people pleaser
in us it's the vigilance side where
we're paying attention
to everything outside of ourselves to
the point where we start to
overvalue other people's opinions we
start to think they know
what's best for us or again that there's
a right way to do something
we get caught up in those shoulds and we
don't develop
you know i really believe that listening
to your gut is a muscle
and so it's something that can be
developed if you give it
attention what does that mean is it
getting out of your own way
is it it's not acting on impulse it's
not acting on instinct what is it
no so you know gut gut hunch
intuition i group them all is the same
thing which is
basically listening to yourself and
sensitive shrivers we have
a more advanced ability to do this
because of our processing because we're
attuning to more that's happening around
us
we're taking that in more we're
processing that information in a more
complex
intricate way it's like we have a a
bigger database
to be pulling from so intuition you want
to think of it a little bit like
a pattern matching game where
when you have to make a decision or a
choice your brain in the matter
fractions of a millisecond is doing
these calculations
pulling from all of your past
experiences your
preferences your learnings uh your
memories
and is calculating how is this situation
like the past
and how can i use information to provide
as much of an analog to what's happening
now about how i should behave
and so as a sensitive shriver we have a
deeper well
to pull from and intuition
it can feel a little you know woo-woo or
spiritual
or fluffy because it is so unconscious
and
and fast but it is really that it's
beyond awareness
it's almost that physiological response
of
something in my gut and in my body feels
right
or i call it like a um an internal
traffic light
when your intuition says something is a
go you feel like
yes i know this is totally the right
decision for me but when your intuition
says
you know maybe you should stay away or
this isn't good
you feel that resistance inside
it's interesting i've been thinking
about this a lot recently trying to get
out of
our own way with things like just get
rid of the cerebral front brain
stuff um and this is one of the problems
i see in the personal development and
the
self-growth world generally that when
you're constantly striving to try and be
better
you inevitably lose a degree of
confidence in your own
existing skill set because there's
something inherent about oh well i've
got to acquire more because i need i
need to know about that thing and i need
to
improve my communication and i need to
be out with this and
that and the other and i think
one of the things that would be really
interesting if people were able to do it
would be to periodize their
years perhaps and say okay so maybe for
a couple of months i'm going to focus on
growing and then for a couple of months
i'm not i'm not going to be too bothered
about actually trying to acquire new
skills
i'm just going to allow the existing
ones i have to kind of permeate
the actions that i do and then you go
okay wow like look what happens when i
get out of my own way and i just allow
that stuff to flow
um yeah the the unconscious
insights that we get i think it's easy
in
the modern era where and you know we're
here talking about personal development
but letting it go every so often and
just saying right i'm just going to have
faith that the system and all the stuff
i've acquired is just going to
amalgamate somewhere in the back of my
brain or the base of my stomach
and it's going to arrive when it's
needed yeah and you know
as sensitive shrivers the the research
shows that we are
great synthesizers that goes back to
what i was saying before about the
neuroscience that
shows our brain patterns we make more
neural connections
between information but we need
space to do that so what you were saying
you know about
um really creating the opportunity to
listen to yourself
uh reminded me that when i was writing
the book i'm a huge reader i love
books i read tons of personal
development books you can see them
all behind me if you're watching the
video but when
through the process of writing the book
i stopped reading
other books because i knew it was
extremely important for me to be
listening to myself
and my own knowledge and not reading
another book and saying oh but maybe i
should try to incorporate this or make
my book look like that
so that was something i did to create
space to allow my intuition to come
through
and to trust myself that i would
synthesize all of my
education and learning and background
into this book
and not cloud it with um very
worthwhile information but
it would prevent me from hearing myself
that's really smart
i did a tedx talk a couple of months ago
and
i was brought on last minute for a talk
that had already been delayed by a year
so the 2021 had got pushed back to 2021
and then a couple of people had dropped
out when they'd announced it was the
rearranged date and they gave me so i
had 10 weeks
and most of the other people who'd been
on it had had
like 14 or 15 months i think to prepare
or even maybe
maybe even more and um so many of the
people
that were doing their talks had found
that what they'd written
a year ago they now disagreed with they
now had these internal conflicts around
because they had moved on the
talk that they had written and the
person that they then were
were jarred somehow and in a bizarre way
i knew that within the space of 10 weeks
my opinions can change quite quickly but
they're not going to change usually
about something that was as core as what
i was going to talk about and i actually
felt like it was an advantage
i actually thought oh okay well i have
similar to you
periodizing intake with output
i didn't have sufficient time to change
my fundamental views around the topic i
was going to talk on
so i didn't get that oh well maybe
what is my position around whether being
weird is a competitive or a social
advantage or what is my position around
this than the other
so um yeah bizarrely it can be it can be
an advantage like that
another thing that you talk about is to
do with with boundaries
and i think that's quite interesting
inevitably if you are a sensitive
striver someone that wants to over
deliver and over achieve
you're going to take your work home with
you and
to reply to emails on the weekend and do
all that sort of stuff
why are boundaries so hard to build and
how can people build them
oh gosh now more than ever they're so
difficult because
there is no we don't have artificial
boundaries anymore between our
professional lives and our personal
lives
we used to have for most people used to
go into the office or
co-working space you would have your
commute it's time to
transition into that professional
mindset now there is no
separation between that and for many
people you have kids at home so your
home is also school
there's just there's no uh external
boundaries as much anymore so it's a
huge challenge now
but especially for sensitive shrivers
the misunderstanding
about boundaries is that they make you
mean you're having to be
harsh and it goes against that identity
that we have as being helpful to people
and wanting to please people for example
but in the book i really go into the
fact that
boundaries are meant to be helpful to
both you
and other people so they serve other
people as well because clear is kind
and people need to know where you stand
and how to get the best out of you and
boundaries
are what help us with that yeah
it's um i've got cal newport coming on
uh later this week in his new books a
world without email
and um so i'm gonna go really deep on on
this but um
yeah it's it's weird because if you're
fortunate enough to do something that
you love
you can almost let it kill you you know
if you do end up blending the passion
with the boundarylessness
of life it can become a very dangerous
combination and that's before you say oh
well
what if i'm not actually that enamored
with my job or what if my boss is a bit
of a dick
that makes it even worse so we've talked
a lot about self-confidence and stuff
today but you have an entire
chapter which is dedicated to strategies
for it what are some of your favorite
strategies
for achieving self-confidence or
improving it
yeah well you know for boundaries in
particular i think this is important one
and i want to stay there because this is
actually an area where you can
use your emotions to your advantage and
setting boundaries
improves your confidence because you're
actually regarding yourself your time
as important as worthy of something when
you don't have any boundaries you're
basically sending that signal
to your subconscious that you're not
important you don't matter
everybody else matters a lot more than
you so
with boundaries i always tell clients to
start with
using the data found in your emotions
in the book i go into a more
comprehensive assessment
but i would be urging listeners to look
for the emotion of resentment
so bitterness or indignation
uh towards a person or a situation you
know let's say
you are feeling resentful that you said
you would help out a colleague with
something and now it's been six months
and you know there's no sign of that
changing they said it would be temporary
and you're feeling resentful
that's a sign that a boundary needs to
be set so that motion
can be very instructive and
it can really improve your confidence to
start
setting those boundaries because you
have to be more assertive
you have to speak up about your needs
and your wants and like i said you start
to prove to yourself
that you're valuable but you know more
importantly
your confidence increases
with the number of promises you keep to
yourself
so if you are someone that always says
well i'm going to make time to work out
tonight
and then well you know what i said i had
to get this thing back to
my boss let me just do that instead i
can work out over the weekend
and you keep pushing it every time you
do that you lose a little bit of
credibility
with yourself you are teaching yourself
you can't
trust yourself so setting
making and keeping those small
commitments is huge to improving your
confidence
by and far that is the number one thing
that i work on with clients building
that momentum
building that chain of small wins
helps you internalize that you can trust
yourself
but then also reflecting on those wins
so i always advocate that my clients
have a brag file
which is a place where you can record
your accomplishments
and accomplishments can be defined as
things went great and knocked it out of
the park
but also moments of strength where i
overcame resistance or had to make a
tough decision
those are all brags for sure and the
process of
pausing to note those down again sends
the signal to
your mind that this is important that
this is not just
okay yeah today was fine move on to the
next thing or
the negativity bias taking over of all
these great things happen
but i got one piece of negative feedback
and an email from a reader
and that totally decimates my day it
helps balance out that negativity bias
the we're totally aligned on that with
regards to confidence
i think people mistakenly believe
that confidence is something that's
bestowed on you and it's not something
that's given it's earned
do you have the right to be confident
it's the same as it kind of links back
to the imposter syndrome thing like if
if you are performing or the expectation
of you is miles outside of anything
you've ever achieved before then
you might actually have the right to be
unconfident
that you're going to be able to do it
but you can still approach that with a
level of adventure and vigor
and energy and think well if i if i'd
if even i don't believe i can do this
then what have i got to lose that's
another way to reframe it right
there's two two quotes that i absolutely
adore from
um things that i've read recently one is
naval ravicant and he says self-esteem
is the reputation you have with yourself
you'll always know and that very much
kind of
relates to what you said there it's the
friend that you invite out for dinner if
they kept on not turning up to dinner
you wouldn't invite them anymore that is
very much the way that you and your
internal monologue have a relationship
i had stephen kotler the founder of the
flow research project on the show a
little while ago
and he said that he actually bifurcates
the planning self and the executing self
into
two different people to improve his
confidence and his accountability
and um he had this friend that he
learned it from
and he asked his friend about his level
of discipline and about how he did the
things that he needed to do when it came
to doing them
and he said i don't know what you're
talking about man i just work for the
boss
and he referred to himself as his own
boss and i was like that is
so cool to have that separation
of the system one and the system two of
the planning and of the executing
and i'm just working for the boss i
thought that was so sick a really
really cool way to use it yeah and
you know that that gets to this idea of
i'm sure
many of your past guests have talked
about this the idea of decision
fatigue which is that we only have a
certain amount
of energy to go around every day and if
you're wasting
your energy on inconsequential
choices or thoughts well then you don't
have that for the most important ones
and so really being mindful about how
you're spending
your energy and i even have my clients
do energy tracking
where for you know a week or two they'll
track the activities in their day
and how much they give or take away
energy and that's
that's very telling to see where you can
earn back
time what is what is sucking your time
and where you should lean in
more i imagine that it's
challenging for sensitive strivers to
stand up for themselves without feeling
like they're being too pushy
what's what's a strategy that people can
use to deliver feedback
like forcibly but with tact
yes so because we are people who think
before we speak were were actually very
uh we're well suited to give harsh
not harsh feedback but hard feedback
and you know in in the book i talk about
a
three-step uh or a three-part model for
thinking about how to be more assertive
and i call it the communication trifecta
one
is what you do so those are the actions
you take
being proactive taking initiative to
address problems
before they become a problem and
uh offering solutions
making explicit requests so i see this
all the time
with sensitive shrivers that they will
dance around
what they want but they won't say it
because they're
afraid of being that forward so they
will not clearly state what they want or
ask for what they need
they sort of expect other people to read
between the lines
because because we are good at reading
between lines
exactly but the other 80 doesn't
um so that you have what you do then you
have what you
say which is the actual content of your
message
using your thoughtfulness to your
advantage here
planning planning what you want to say
not extensively
i have clients who will write the whole
script of exactly what they want to say
and then they get in the conference
conversation and it goes a little
sideways and they are totally panicked
because oh my gosh i didn't i didn't
plan for this this wasn't in my script
so really just having planning in terms
of having you know high level structure
of where you want to go and the points
you want to hit so even if the
conversation gets off the rails
you can always come back to those main
points as your anchors
dropping prefaces and qualifiers
because we tend to be a little afraid
of delivering a direct message we often
soften it by saying you know
i know this may sound silly or i may be
wrong
i hope you won't be upset or mad at me
we throw in all those
qualifiers which just undermines the
strength
of what we're saying so much better to
say instead of i hope you won't be mad
at me
but to say i have some important
feedback i want to share with you today
and just cut it out so what you do
what you say and then how you say it
which is your delivery and how you show
up
and luckily again this is where we can
channel our traits to our advantage
sensitive shrivers tend to naturally be
very
warm people right where we easily
connect with and build rapport with
people so
use that um but specifically you know
keep a calm
level tone to your voice your body
language is important
i once had a client who was going into a
very important
uh meeting um actually was a legal
dispute that he was going into and
as we were prepping for this in a
coaching session he was in his chair
going like this and and i'm fidgeting
all over and he was kind of you know
rubbing his head
and i could his nerves were just leaking
out
through his body so you have to remember
that your body
tells a story and that if you need a way
to process your energy
have something in your hand channel it
that way or a quick grounding exercise
is to really ball your hands up
in a fist and then let it go and imagine
that you're letting go
of the energy as you do that and then
last i would say in the
how you say it is making choices around
context
and again this is where our our nuanced
thinking comes in in that you will know
other people are not as tactful to they
may deliver
some hard feedback over slack for
example where all
uh nuance is lost and something doesn't
land well
whereas you may know that you know this
is this is something i have to have as a
face to face or a video conversation
with someone so just making wise choices
about
the medium the timing is this something
you want to
tell someone at the beginning of the
morning or do you want to make sure you
don't have a
a meeting planned right after that so
you have to rush the conversation
um so just being thoughtful around that
as well it's so interesting about how
the unique advantages that are bestowed
on someone that's empathetic but driven
is where you need to kind of utilize
that's exactly what all of these
insights are growing out of
right okay so use that use the
perception right
how are you going to speak to the person
what is it that you're going to say
what's the delivery going to be like is
it going to be done in the morning
what's that going to make the rest of
their day look like
if you tell them on an evening are they
going to go home and immediately stew
with their family like
you know is it best to do it just after
lunch when everybody's energized or is
it best to do it in the morning when
they've just got it
yeah i think i think that's really good
um what about setbacks
i imagine that they must be the sort of
thing that can sometimes hurt
yeah because sensitive shrivers tend to
personalize them
we tend to rather than seeing setbacks
as
a very natural part of the journey and
uh you know seth godin talks about the
dip
which in in management and business
uh in economic theory it's called the
change curve
which means that whenever you're on uh
pursuing any sort of change or advancing
yourself
there comes a natural point where you
hit a down cycle
where you may feel a little bit hopeless
or disappointed or dismayed
so rather than realizing that something
that's very predictable
and normative sensitive shrivers tend to
personalize
setbacks and let it steal all of our
motivation
because we make it mean something about
us
and that's my golden coaching question
that i ask clients whenever they feel
stuck in something is what are you
making this mean
about you and how true is that or
also how helpful is that story
so yes that is why setbacks are so hard
for sensitive shrivers but this is where
also so much of what we've talked about
so far
comes back into play to help you get out
of that setback
so in the book i talk about
a process of resting reflecting
and recalibrating so resting
is pretty much taking some time away
from the problem
really addressing your own physiological
reaction to it because you may go into
panic you may feel hurt um and you don't
want to force yourself
to find the silver lining in a situation
because most of the time
again i think we try to bypass that pain
rather than
addressing it and if we don't address
those emotions
they're going to come out in some other
way so resting is really about
addressing the internal reaction of your
thoughts and your emotions
to the setback then we have reflect
and reflect is reflecting on
your successes reflecting on what you
have
the hard things you have overcome in the
past consulting your intuition and what
it's telling you
going back to your core values and
what's most important to you
and how does that factor into how you
want to make a decision here
and then recalibrating is about choosing
a path forward
so maybe you need to recommit to or
reset
your goals maybe your goals were too sky
high or you need to eliminate
some and give up some goals like we
talked about earlier
maybe you need to build new boundaries
because the situation has changed or you
found
uh the setback was a result of not
having proper boundaries in the first
place
and you know maybe you need to find a
different situation for yourself
we didn't talk too much about this but
sensitive shrivers
are highly affected by their environment
again because we're picking up on
everything around us
the environment is more important so the
research does show
that sensitive people who are in
supportive positive environments tend to
have higher performance
than the average person but when we're
in negative unsupportive environments
tend to have worse performance than the
average person so
choosing and constructing your
environment to
work for you is hugely important to
making sure you can
lift yourself out of that setback and
stay out of it and it's those mirror
neurons again as well though right
yes that's right it seems like a common
arc between all of the things we're
talking about here is just
giving the sensitive strivers of the
people that are taking in more
information and feeling things a bit
more deeply
just giving them that room between
all of the thoughts that are going on
and kind of trying to let
let that go it really does seem like
that's probably one of the core tenets
that's coming through
it's making your inner world a
friendlier place
i love it melody wilding ladies and
gentlemen trust yourself stop
overthinking and channel your emotions
for success at work
will be linked in the show notes below
where else should people go if they want
to check out your stuff
you can head to melodywilding.com you
can find out more from me there i have
hundreds of articles a free community
you can join and would love to see you
awesome thank you for coming on thank
you so much for having me
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace
you